to me you you obviously and Joe are the
two biggest podcasters I don't know if
that's like factual I don't have some
influencer has some podcasts but you
guys interview folks that I listen to
more
more often than anybody else and when
Magnus came on I was like oh this is
that's amazing you know I I don't even
know how I would reach out to Someone
Like You it just seems like a a limp
like climbing a mountain and then a
couple days later and I even in that
episode wanted to write but I didn't
know how it's like do I make a YouTube
comment I don't want that I'm looking
like I'm clout chasing on the Magnus
episode but then you talked about Texas
and I said oh what's this I shouldn't
overthink it yeah like you know I so I
just said all right [ __ ] it I'll just
write a comment and you're like yeah I'd
love to have you on I was shocked I
didn't even you responded just within a
couple hours or something yeah yeah I
loved it man I mean it was an honor it's
a good way to connect I also like on
live streams I'll watch I'll try to
resist commenting but
um
you know I'll watch some some even
smaller channels like I'll get super
excited by by them and connect in that
way there's an intimacy to that man
YouTube is beautiful I don't know
anything about twitch maybe it's similar
to know anything about it but YouTube
has ruined you there's an intimacy like
especially if it's live I don't know
what that is but if it's live they're
like right there
you can just like reach out and say
hello yes cool it's like really uh I
don't know
I'm just happy to live in this time when
you could connect with people in that
way there is an intimacy that's why I
love podcasts too I I listen to people
and I feel like they're my friend
it's cool it's a cool it's a cool
feeling it makes you feel less lonely
um in this world like you have a
lifelong companion especially like
people that do a podcast for many many
years I'm like we've been you've gone
through all the ups and downs of life
together with a creator with uh with a
podcaster with anything it's cool I
don't know it makes it um it's
surprisingly intimate a one-way
friendships
there's some negatives that people
Definitely describe the word that gets
used a lot is parasocial you think you
you like the viewer will think that the
the streamer or the YouTuber knows them
or owes them something or has some they
have a bigger connection than they do
but you know what actually because I had
to interrupt I have to look maybe you
can explain to me I've heard this term
parasocial a lot I've been meaning to
look it up might as well look it up well
in live on the podcast sure Paris social
interaction PSI refers is this a new
term because I have just started
listening hearing it like the last yeah
I think it's years yeah
parasocial interaction PSI refers to
kind of psychological relationship
experienced by an audience in their
mediated encounters with performance in
the mass media particularly on
television and on online platforms
viewers or listeners come to consider
media personalities as friends despite
having no or limited interaction with oh
[ __ ] that's a term for a thing of
been referring to interesting the term
was coined by Donald Horton and Richard
wall in 1956. wow when there was like a
very limited media huh wow I guess TV
and radio and stuff yeah yeah parasocial
interaction and exposure The Gamers
interested in the Persona become a
parasocial relationship after repeated
exposure to the media yeah okay what's
the downside bro what's what's okay oh
well I can tell you the downside the
downside is is people thinking they're
in relationships with streamers and
stalking them that's or the Stalking
Part but the relationship is like
I mean okay you mean like actual
relationship like
like waking up and saying how are you
doing like in your head to them yeah no
but that might be an extension more like
yeah getting mad they don't respond to
you in
anytime you're in the Stream or that
convincing yourself the other person
wants you and
you need to go to them so you need to
find where they are like this has
happened some of the biggest female
streamers have reported that
they get stalked and harassed for months
and that's born out of this
this on a very small scale is
you come into a stream every so often
and give an update about your academic
career that's not so bad I I was going
to mention I've streamed on Twitch for
years and I watched people have kids
like people will come in over the course
of months and say hey man you know I
just finished I just took the bar exam
yo man like I'm having my first kid and
that's crazy that's that's amazing yeah
but if they do it in a healthy way
that's one thing
but there's always gonna be downsized
but most of it is beautiful man nice I
have uh very uh I have I guess
parasocial relationships uh of people
that take it a little too far
but it's all love you also have a
fundamental belief and hope in people to
be good
yeah yeah yeah and I've been you know I
haven't gotten in trouble with it yet
that's that's a good thing me too I've
interacted with plenty people in person
and no one's been negative so yes and
I've even gone to a war zone uh there I
can't there's no there hasn't been uh
people have been very
I don't know uh people have
only surprised me in the positive
direction in the depth of the the
capacity they have for compassion